my next guest grew up in Ireland and
fell in love with fashion at a very
young age but at 3 foot 5 clothes from
pages of Vogue were not exactly meant
for someone her size so she set out to
change that she started a blog which led
to a TED talk which then led to rubbing
elbows with everyone from Oprah to Kim
Kardashian her message is simple the
world should be designed for everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
you look cute and all those little lips
and lipstick I like that outfit so your
family played a pretty big part in your
activism correct
yeah well firstly this is Prada let's
take it not Prado which you can get on
another Street but yeah if I'm in any
way a success it's because I'm a loves
child and I grew up with this very
visceral understanding of I could do
whatever it is that I wanted so in my
family I'm the eldest of five children I
have three sisters and one brother all
of whom are average height like
everybody else on the sofa but my dad is
a little person just like me
yeah and growing up and having somebody
there who looked so much like me really
underlined this thing that anything was
possible because my dad survived and
thrived and he was just this amazing
individual who always said that I could
do whatever and I always wanted to be a
teacher I started out my career as an
elementary school teacher and while I
was in university we started a blog and
the idea of it was that as a teacher you
would write this blog because when your
kids come home from school you say to
them what did you do today and your
child says nothing exactly a girl but
that's somebody I'm like what is she
doing well they never tells me and the
lecture and the lecture and the surprise
I said you can write about anything you
want in this blog so I wrote about K
planchette wearing Givenchy Couture to
the Oscars because I had always this
innate interest in fashion because
there's somebody who was a disabled
woman if I sit across from you in a
Prada silk dress that's from a recent
collection you're like oh she's
interesting and yet fashion was never
considerate of people like me as the
eldest of all of my sisters I would
bring them shopping they would pick up a
pair of high heels in the store and I
would try and wear them - and they were
like no this doesn't fit you and I
remember just thinking this was so
unjust not only because I was more
interest
in the industry but because we legally
each have to wear clothes and if this is
something that we all have to summarize
down States but why do we not all get to
participate because it's part of our
identity it touches our skin so this
blog then evolved today I'm getting to
do a TED talk to talk about why design
should be inclusive for everybody that
it wasn't just something that was
facetious but it could change the world
yeah and from that got to be on the
cover of Vogue and go to the Met fell I
mean it's water and I love that you I
found out you were the first little
person ever got to go to the Met Gala
right they ever attended and get to the
carpet what was that like I've never
been an absolutely terrified they're all
yelling at you like on the carpet it's
so nerve-wracking but it was this
extraordinary thing where nobody had
ever been there who looked like me
before and if you can't see it you can't
be it and for me you know you woke up 23
steps it was talking about Anna Wintour
who's the editor-in-chief of American
Vogue talking to her about accessibility
at the Met Gala what does it look like
when we take an institution like the Met
and make it open to everyone so the Met
Gala is an event that happens once a
year it's a fundraiser for the fashion
department in the museum and it is
anybody who we think we should be
listening to in the world in many ways
are probably invited and the tickets are
ludicrously expensive I went with a
brand like Gucci and Anna Wintour ticks
off everybody who gets to go and to be
there I felt a sense of pressure that
whether I liked it or not despite only
being able to speak for myself I was
representing not just people who look
like me but people with disabilities in
general because so often they're just
not part of our conversation even when
we talk about inclusion and diversity
disability is not even something or a
word that we use because if people
aren't directly impacted by it on an
everyday basis they're not even it's not
even the forefront of their mind it's
not something we think of and Dad
ignorant is often not malicious but
that's not an excuse for us not to be
facilitating the conversation so where
you go to something like the Met Gala
and you get to wear this magnificent
dress that's now on display in the Gucci
Garden in Florence like what does the
person who sees that sitting at home
scrolling through Twitter and Instagram
what did they now think is possible for
them and how long does it take before
the next little
person gets to go to the mikela like I
hope it's this year so how have you
carried this message though to so many
powerful people how do you do just walk
up I go to events I've been to this
industry for nearly 20 years and I still
don't talk to people I'm like I ain't
gonna talk unless spoken to unless I
freaked meryl streep at once but yeah
but I'm just saying that's bold just to
walk up to people I live in a body where
people are unsure so often how to
interact with me and that discomfort can
sometimes bring about an apathy and the
conversation doesn't occur so since I've
been very very young I've had to step
into it and be proud of the body that I
live in and yeah I've walked up to Anna
Wintour or the people I admire most I'm
like hi I'm Sinead I think your work is
incredible I think we should have a
conversation and I think we should talk
about design more broadly and in many
ways that's probably what allows me to
do something like be a podcast host I
have a show called as me with Sinead and
I asked for questions to every single
guests including Jamie Lee Curtis
Victoria Beckham dan levy and one of the
questions I ask is what's it like to
live in your body because my experience
is so explicit well most of the time I
forget that I'm a little person until I
can't reach something or I'm reminded
and I think that's all of us and what's
the potential when we realize that so
many of our challenges are not in
isolation like we all struggle we all
feel alone we all feel like we can't do
things or are not represented and what
happens when we realize that so does
Kelly Clarkson yeah girls Paul Wesley
so does Lily sing you're like oh if they
can do like why not me
I just I love what I think what I love
most is I mean I grew up in church so I
just love hearing you know people preach
and talk and live something that they're
very passionate about and they're very
into and they're so eloquently spoken at
it as well it's it's so cool it's just
inspiring and as me with Sinead is
available to download wherever you can
get your podcast and I am so into it I
can I'm in love with you I think you're
just such a great person you're speaking
to like not only little people you're
speaking to the world in a sense of
breaking down those barriers and I love
that I think it's really we need to stop
living in fear and I agree with you so
thank you for that message but I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this